[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
معكم محمد كريشان في هذه اللحظات عواصم
ومدن في العالم تعيش على وقع احدث هامه
هذه الصور المباشره تاتينا من عاصمه
النيجر ميامي وترقب لموقف هناك من قاده
الانقلاب بعد انتهاء اجتماعا لقاده اركان
اكواس وحديثهم عن خطه للتدخل العسكري
المحتمل
هذه الصور الان من منتجع الكامب ديفيد في
ولايه ماريلاند الامريكيه حيث عقدت قمه
امريكيه يابانيه كوريه جنوبيه وحديث عن
تحالف جديد
وفي مواضيع الحصاد بهذه الليله
في ختام اجتماعاتهم في اكرى قاده جيوش
يضعون صيغه النهائيه للتدخل العسكري في
النيجر
مفوض المجموعه يقول ان الخطه جاهزه
للتنفيذ في انتظار قرار قاده المجموعه
ويشدد على ان الهدف ليس شن حرب على النيجر
بل استعاده النظام الدستوري
مزيد من الهجمات في الداخل الروسي مسيره
اوكرانيه تستهدف موسكو والدفاع الروسيه
تعترضها دون وقوع سبك
واشنطن توافق على قيام الدنمارك وهولندا
بتزويد اوكرانيا بمقاتلات اف 16 والقوات
الاوكرانيه تؤكد للجزيره انها ستغير مسار
الحرب
تنقل عن مسؤولين امريكيين ان خسائر القوات
الروسيه والاوكرانيه بلغت نصف مليون بين
قتيل وجريح
قمه امريكيه يابانيه كوريه جنوبيه في
كامبيفيد الدول الثلاث تؤكد انها بدايه
حقبه جديده في الشراكه الثلاثيه وتشدد على
تعزيز تحالف طويل الامد في ظل مناخ
المنافسه الجيويه السياسيه
وبجيل تحذر من تداعيات تحويل منطقه اسيا
والمحيط الهادئ الى ساحه منافسه جيوسياسيه
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه كنا نقشنا معكم ما اوردته صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز عن المسؤولين امريكيين بان
النصف مليون نصف مليون بين قتيل وجريح
سقطوا منذ بدي حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
والحديث حصرا عن خسائر الجيشين لاستطلاع
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي والسؤال يقول الى اي
مدى تؤثر الخسائر البشريه في الجيشين
الروسيه والاوكراني على مسار الحرب كيف
جاءت النتائج النتائج جاءت على النحو
التالي نحو 70% قالوا ان التاثير سيكون
كبيرا على امد الحرب بحين صوت نحو 30%
بالقول انه لا تاثير لهذه الخسائر البشريه
على مسار الحرب هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا
على منصات الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا
على الشاشه
[موسيقى]
الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا
مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
في اي اتجاه تسير الامور في النيجر وهل
باتت البلاد قاب قوسين او ادنى من استعاده
النظام الدستوري فيها بالقوه خلال يومين
من اجتماعات قاده اركان الدول المجموعه
الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا في العاصمه
الغنيه اكرا جرى الاتفاق على خطه تدخل
عسكري محتمل من اجل اعاده النظام الدستوري
هناك مفوض السلم والامن في مجموعه عبد
الفتاح موسى اعلن خلال تصريحات صحفيه في
نهايه الاجتماع ان المجموعه لم تقفل جميع
الابواب ولكنها لم تنخرط في مفاوضات لا
افق لها
[موسيقى]
انا هنا لاقول لكم اننا جاهزون للتدخل
عندما يصدر الامر بذلك وقد قررنا بالفعل
اليوم المحدد الذي سننفذ فيه التدخل لكننا
لن نعلن عنه اليوم ولن يجتمع رؤساء
الاركان بعد الان
واذا حصل واجتمعوا فسيكون ذلك لادخال اي
تعديلات تحتاجها العمليه العسكريه وهذا هو
الاجتماع الثاني والاخير قبل اطلاق هذه
القوات
اتخذت اكواس اذا قرارها لكنها من ناحيه
اخرى وضعت لنفسها خطا للرجعه باعلانها ان
المجموعه لا تزال منفتحه على جهود الوساطه
واذا لمست مواقف ايجابيه من خلال الجهود
المطروحه فان المجموعه مستعده لقبول هذه
الجهود وكان رئيس المجلس الاوروبي شارل
ميشيل قد اكد خلال اتصال مع رئيس نيجيريا
ان الاتحاد الاوروبي لن يعترف بالسلطات
الناتجه عن الانقلاب في النيجر وقال ميشيل
خلال الاتصال ان الرئيس بازوم المنتخب
الديمقراطيا يبقى الرئيس الشرعي لدوله
النيجر بينما حذر الرئيس نيجيريا بولا
تينوبو من ان صحه الرئيس بازوم اخذه في
التده ور وان استمرار تدهورها ستكون له
عواقب وخيمه
الثابت ان الموقف في النيجر على ضوء
التطورات المتلاحقه منذ انقلاب السادس
والعشرين من يوليو الماضي يظل مفتوحا على
مختلف الاحتمالات وان كانت تدخل ايكواس
عسكريا صار اقرب براي كثيرين
ومعنى حاليا من يوم من نيامي سنوسي محمد
المنسق العام لحركه امن 62 المناهده
للوجود الفرنسي في البلاد ومن ابو جا
الجنرال المتقاعد رئيس السابق للتطوير
الدفاعي بوزاره الدفاع وزميل كليه الدفاع
الوطني في نيجيريا اهلا بضيفين نبدا من
نيامي سيد سنوسي محمد الى اي مدى هناك وعي
في النيجر بان التدخل العسكري بات وشيكا
الان
شكرا جزيلا
وكما تعرفون منذ
التدخل الكلاب العسكري 23
من تموز يوليا
بلدنا
تتعرض لتهديدات التدخل عسكري من قبل فرنسا
عن طريق
الاكواس ولكن كما لاحظتم ان جميع الدول
لاكواس حاليا
بداوا بالتراجع فيما يتعلق بهذا المشروع
مشروع التدخل العسكري في النيجر والسبب هو
ان شعوب المختلفه لدول الاكواس يعارضون
هذا المشروع مشروع العدوان العسكري على
النيجر وهو البلد عضو في هذه المنظمه هو
ان البرلمان ومجال البرلمانات هذه الدول
المختلفه كلها ضد هذا التدخل العسكري في
النيجر
عدد تلك الدول حتى الدول الافريقيه الاخرى
العالم كله يقف ضد هذا العدوان العسكري ضد
النيجر
وسبب ان كل العالم متفقون اننا تدخل
العسكري ليس هو الحرب القوه ليست هي الحل
وبالتالي ففي كل انحاء العالم اليوم هناك
دعوه الى المفاوضات والى المنهج
الدبلوماسي الذي يسمح بحل هذه المشاكل
ولكن بمرور الزمان كل العالم بدا يفهم بان
فرنسا فرنسا ماكرون هي التي تصر عن طريق
بعض رؤساء الدول
الاكواس خاصه الرئيس حسن الوتره وماكيسال
لانه
البرلمان النيجيري فان رئيس النيجو
التراجع وايضا الدول الاخرى كلها الاعضاء
في
غير موافقين ولكن
اسمح لي بالمقاطعه انت تتحدث عن تراجع
ولكن لا وجود لاي مؤشر تراجع الحديث الان
عن يوم محدد عن حسم في موضوع الخيار
العسكري ولو انه ليس الخيار المفضل وهنا
انتقل للجنرال المتقاعد هنري ايولا لاساله
ما اذا كان الامر فعلا سيمضي قدما نحو
التدخل العسكري رغم كل شيء
هل بامكانك ان تعيد السؤال لو سمحت سؤالي
كان ما اذا كنا فعلا سنذهب الى التدخل
العسكري في النيجر
شكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه بالتاكيد فان
عاده من المعتاد
مسؤولين
العسكريين وحسب عقيده الاكواس كانوا
يعملون بجهد من اجل تفعيل القوه
الاحتياطيه
للكواسي في اي عمليه عسكريه يجب التخطيط
لها قبل وقت مبكر كل ما يقومون به الان
محاوله تلبيه متطلبات اي عمليه بالتاكيد
تم التاكيد ان هذا الامر تم التفكير به
على انه الملاذ الاخير نعم بلاذ اخير ونحن
نامل ان
جديه الجهود الدبلوماسيه
ستؤدي الى نتيجه
لا تستدعي التدخل العسكري هذا هو املنا
بالتاكيد لكن العسكريون في الاكواس عليهم
ان يستمروا في العمل ولا يجب ان ناخذ
المساله الحل العسكري على انه امر مسلم به
سيد ايوب ضيفنا من نيامي سيد سنوسي محمد
صور اكواس وكانها تابعه بالكامل لفرنسا
وبالتالي فالقرار هو قرار فرنسي التنفيذ
وتنفيذ هل تساطر هذا الراي
لا اعتقد انا اوافق معه على الاطلاق لان
الاكواز في الوقت الذي تاخذ فيه لاكواس
هذه الخطوه لاسباب عديده وجيها كما قلته
والملاذ الاخير لكن من اجل ان يتم هنالك
اي
عمليات الردع في دول اخرى في الاكواس من
الجيد ان يكون هنالك احترام
لما يحصل
احترام ووضع انذار لعمليه تفادي لاي
انقلابات اخرى
في حقيقه الامر من الجيد للاكواز ان تضمن
انها تشجعوا اي انقلابات اضافيه في دول
غربي افريقيا
وهم يقومون بذلك من اجل وضع قوه الردع هذه
وان تكون متهيئه بالتالي اي طرف او اي
طرف في اي دوله تحاول ان تفكر في القيام
بانقلاب تعرف انها ستواجهون نتائج انا
اعرف ان هنالك ربما عوامل ضغط داخليه
وخارجيه
والحقيقه اسمح لي بالمقاطعه السيد ايولا
ان ايكوال لسيد سنوسي محمد
بررت قرارها بسبب ما وصفته بتعنت القاده
الانقلابيين وقالت بان الغرض من العمليه
هو وضع حد لمسلسل الانقلابات في هذه
المنطقه من القاره الافريقيه الا تراه
سببا وجيها
محمد السؤال السيد سنوسي محمد
له يعرف
انه لو كان في الحقيقه ان الاخوه لو كانت
فعلا مؤسسه
تسعى
اعاده الديمقراطيه او للحمايه الديمقراطيه
فقد حصلت حالات في تشاد وشاهدنا كيف ان
الاكواس
وقاده الدول المختلفه في كيف تصرفوا
وشاهدنا ايضا
انتهاكات الدستور في حصلت في كوت ديفوار
وترويق قد الولايه الثالثه بعدد كبير من
القتلى ولم يفعل الكواس اي شيء وايضا
شاهدنا في السنغال
ماكيسه يحاول يقوم به ولم يفعل له ولم يقل
لكواس اي شيء فيما يتعلق من انتهاكات
الدستور
الذي يقوم بهما كيسالي ضد الشعب السنغالي
الافارقه قد فهموا جيد بان الاخوه منظمه
ليس لديها رايء خاص بها وهي فقط تتبع
الموقف الفرنسي في انه في الازمه الحاليه
القائم حاليا في النيجر لو ان موقف فرنسا
كان مؤيد المفاوضات والدبلوماسيه
للضموا الى ذلك الموقف الفرنسي
للطالب بمفاوضات ولكن
عندما تقفون الى جانب
الانقلاب
رغم كل شيء الا تعتقدون بانكم انما تبهدون
لاستمرار هذا المسلسل سياتي عسكر اخرون
وينقلبون على هؤلاء العسكر ويستمر المسلسل
طالما ان هناك حكم سيء وطالما ان هناك
مشاكل امنيه طالما هناك فساد لعم البلاد
وطالما ان المؤسسات الجمهوريه لا تعمل
بطريقه نظاميه وجيده وطالما كان هناك رئيس
يحرر
الارهابيين ويؤكد ذلك وفي التالي يصبح من
الطبيعي ان يتدخل الجيش في الحياه
السياسيه ويستولي على السلطه هذا في
الواقع يرتبط بتصرف
اطراف او الاشخاص السياسيين في البلاد
وطريقه ادارتهم للباشون البلاد الكل كان
يعرف انه في قبل هذا انقلاب لم تكن اي
حريات في نيجيري كان في الضغط على كل
الفضاء الديمقراطي وكان هناك انتهاكات
للحقوق الانسان وشكرا وبالت
شكرا شكرا جزيلا شكرا جزيلا لك سيد سنوسي
محمد بن يامي وشكرا ايضا لضيفنا من بوجا
الجنرال المتقاعد هذه
اذا مفوض اكواس قال انما يجري في النيجر
جزء من سلسله انقلابات بالمنطقه تحاول
المجموعه وضع حد لها ويصادف اليوم الذكرى
الثالثه لاول تلك الانقلابات في مالي
قبل ثلاث سنوات انطلقت في مالي شراره
انقلابات عسكريه لا تزال تعصف حتى اليوم
في دول غرب افريقيا ففي الثامنه عشر من
اغسطس 2020 شهدت باماكو تمردا عسكريا
انتهى باعتقال الرئيس ابراهيم بوبكر كيتا
المنتخب لولايه رئاسيه ثانيه واجباره على
الاستقاله اطاحه كيتا جاءت وسط مظاهرات
شعبيه طالبت برحيله ورفعت شعارات مناهضه
للنفذ الفرنسي الذي تعزز عسكريا منذ نشر
باريس قوات لها ضمن عمليتين وبرخان
بعد نحو تسعه اشهر اطاح انقلاب ثاني في
مالي السلطه الانتقاليه ليتصدر العقيد
اسيمي جويته المشهد ويتولى رئاسه
الانتقاليه في البلاد وقد توجه بويتان نحو
روسيا التي عززت تعاون العسكريه معها في
الخامس من سبتمبر 2021
اطاح العقيد في الجيش الغني ممادو دومبيا
الرئيسه الفاكوندي الذي كان قد عدل
الدستور من اجل الترشح لولايه دستوريه
ثالثه ولم يكد الشهر الاول من عام 2022
ينتهي حتى اطاح ضباط في جيش بوركينا فاسو
يتزعمهم المقدم صن داوودو داميبا الرئيس
المنتخب حينها لولايه ثانيه روكابوري
لاحقا وفي الثلاثين من سبتمبر من العام
نفسه اطاح الكابتن ابراهيم تراوري المقدم
داميبا وتولى مقاليد الحكم في البلاد
وانهى التعاون العسكريه مع فرنسا وعزز
علاقات بلاده مع روسيا اما احدث
الانقلابات العسكريه في المنطقه فكان في
السادس والعشرين من يوليو 2023 حين احتجز
ضباط في الحرس الرئاسي في النيجر يتزعمهم
الجنرال عبد الرحمن تياني رئيس البلاد
المنتخب محمد بازوم واعلن لاحقا تشكيل ما
سموه المجلس الوطني لحمايه الوطن وعينوا
حكومه تتولى تسير الشان العام
[موسيقى]
انا لا سلطات الروسيه احباط هجوما بمسيره
على موسكو وقالت انها غيرت مسارها بعد ان
استهدفتها اسلحه الدفاع الجوي وسقطت على
مبنى غير سكني دون وقوع صبات وقالت
السلطات ان المسيره غيرت مسارها بعد ان
استهدفتها اسلحه الدفاع الجوي وقد اعلنت
هيئه الطيران الروسيه استئناف حركه
الملاحه في اربعه مطارات بموسكو بعد
اغلاقها مؤقتا بالتزامن مع هذا الهجوم
بينما وصفت الخارجيه الروسيه في بيان لها
الهجوم بانه يؤكد ماء وصفته بطبيعتك
الاجراميه
بينما نقلت صحيفه
نيويوركين ان عدد القتلى والمصابين من
القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه في الحرب
يقترب من نصف مليون شخص وبحسب المسؤولين
الامريكيين فان عدد قتل القوات الاوكرانيه
بلغ نحو 70000 بينما يتراوح عدد المصابين
ما بين 100 الف ومائه وعشرين الف في
المقابل تقدر الخسائر في صفوف الجيش
الروسي بنحو ثلاثمائه الف بينهم 120 الف
قتيل
في غضون ذلك اعلنت كل من الدنمارك وهولندا
حصولهما على موافقه امريكيه لارسال طائرات
مقاتله من طراس اف 16 الى اوكرانيا بمجرد
الانتهاء من تدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين
وقال مسؤولون امريكي ان وزير الخارجيه
انطوني بلينكن ارسل خطابين لنظريه
الدنماركي والهولندي يؤكد فيهما دعم بلاده
الكامل لنقل طائرات اف 16 الى اوكرانيا
هذا وتعول اوكرانيا على الطائرات هذه
الطائرات اف 16 لحسم هذه الحرب فقد قال
المتحدث باسم القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه
ان تزويد بلاده بمقاتلات اف 16 من شانه ان
يغير شكل المعركه مع روسيا لكن ما هي
تفاصيل القدرات القتاليه للطائره والدول
المشاركه في تحالف الطائرات الذي سيزود
كييف بهذه المقاتله
تعد طائره اف 16 من اكثر المقاتلات طلبا
حول العالم وتستخدمها قرابه خمس وعشرين
دوله
صنعت شركه جنرال ديناميكس الامريكيه
النموذج الاول منها في سبعينيات القرن
الماضي لصالح سلاح الجو الامريكي دخلت
الخدمه عام
تتميز بخفه وزنها وقدراتها القتاليه
العاليه هجوميا ودفاعيا ويمكن استخدامها
في هجمات مضاده ودعم جوي قريب المدى اضافه
لمهام المراقبه الجويه
يمكنها تحديد الاهداف في جميع الظروف
الجويه واكتشاف الطائرات التي تحلق على
ارتفاعات منخفضه يصل مداها الاقصى لنحو
وبامكانها حمل سته صواريخ تتيح المقاتله
مجال رؤيه خاليا من العوائق في اتجاهي
الامامي والاعلى وبعد ادخال تحديثات عليها
تحسن مجال رؤيه الطيار في الجوانب والخلف
تحتوي على انظمه تحديد مواقع عالميه محسنه
ونظام ملاحه عالي الدقه تقدم اجهزه
الحاسوب على متنها معلومات توجيه للطيارين
ولديها اجراءات مضاده يمكن استخدامها لصد
التهديدات الالكترونيه
تتميز اف 16 ايضا بقوه راداراتها وقدرتها
الفائقه على تحديد الاهداف على الارض هذه
المميزات تجعل من نفس سته عشر مناسبه
لتوفير غطاء جوي للقوات الاوكرانيه اثناء
المعارك البريه مع الجيش الروسي بحسب
خبراء ويمكن لها ان تتيح تقدم القوات برا
وتساعد في صد الطائرات الروسيه تقول كييف
ان هذه الطائرات يمكن ان تتيح لها الدفاع
عن خطوط الشحن البحريه وتامين مغادره
الحبوب الاوكرانيه للبلاد ويقول خبراء ان
حصول اوكرانيا على هذه الطائرات يمكن ان
يغير جوهريا من شكل الصراع باتت اوكرانيا
اقرب من اي وقت مضى للحصول على اف 16 مع
عدم اعتراض امريكي واستعداد بعض الدول
لتزويدها بطائرات من النماذج الاقدم ضمن
ما باتي يعرف بتحالف الطائرات الذي تشكل
في ايار مايو الماضي ويضم احدى عشره دوله
وتقوده هولندا والدنمارك ويشمل ايضا
المانيا وفرنسا وبريطانيا وبولندا وبلجيكا
والبرتغال
[موسيقى]
ومعنا من عاصمه ليتوانيا جيم تاوسند نائب
مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكيه السابق لشؤون
اوروبا ومن موسكو انوف المحلل السياسي
والعسكري نبدا من السيد تاونسن هل فعلا
طائرات اف 16 يمكن ان تغير مجرى الحرب
كلا لا اعتقد انها ستغير من مسار الحرب
اعتقد انها معده مهمه للغايه ولديها
امكانيات عسكريه مهمه مضافه الى اوكرانيا
اذا ما امتلكوا هذه الطائرات اليوم
سيتمكنون من استهداف
والتغلب على العقبات وعلى حقول الغام التي
وضعها الروز بالتالي انه سيوفر لهم غطاء
جوي وتحمي قواتهم على الارض لكن الان انهم
لا يمتلكون هذه الطائرات بالتالي يتحملون
الكثير من الخسائر هي جزء مهم من النظام
الدفاعي الجوي وانا املوا انهم سيحصلوا
على هذه الطائرات في وقت قريب اعتقد انه
قد يحصل عليها السنه القادمه بالتالي
الامر الاوكرانيون سيرحبون بهذا الامر
بالتاكيد ولكن اذا اخذنا الامور كيف تسير
لا يبدو انه في وقت قريب لان سيتم تدريب
الطيارين وبعد ذلك تعطى الطائرات هذه
مساله ستاخ ذ اشهر عديده ربما
نعم نعم انت محق الامر سيتطلب عددا من
الاشهر الطائرات ربما سيتم تسهيم اليها
السنه القادمه واعمل في بدايه العام
المقبل انا ايضا يجب ان يكون هنالك
يكون هنالك مساحات مناسبه لانزالي وهبوط
هذه الطائرات وحقول حقول
ومعدات
لارضيه لاستدامه هذه الطائرات وصيانتها
بالتالي اعتقد انهم سيستلمون هذه الطائرات
السنه القادمه ويتم تشغيلها بالكامل من
قبل
الطيارين الاوكرانيين ولكن السؤال الان
السيد في موسكو الى اي مدى روسيا مستعده
لمثل هذا التطور في سير المعارك
روسيا دائما مستعده لمثل هذا النوع من
التغيير لان اف 16 ليست طائره التفوق جوي
في الحرب
بل هي في المنصه الاطلاق صواريخ بعيد مدام
مثل سكايب وبالتالي فان نقل طائرات اف 16
ودليل على التدمير طائرات اس يو تو 24
والتي الان تستخدم لاطلاق هذه الصواريخ
اذا هذا العدد المحدود من اف 16 لن يغير
شيئا في ساحه المعارك يعني كل هذا الحديث
الذي يجري حول اهميه الحدث تراه لا معنى
له
لا لا قبل قيمه له وهل او الغرض هو فقط
التغطيه اعلاميه
لاظهار او اثبات وحده الغرب وخاصه المتحده
مع اوكرانيا لكن من ناحيه عسكريه هذا
الامر لا يؤثر
اطلاقاو ساند هل هل ترى نفس الراي لا قيمه
لدخول اف 16 الى المعارك
كلا اعتقد ان زميلي مخطئ اعتقد انه سيكون
سيمثل مساعده مهمه لاوكرانيا بالنسبه لان
القوات الروسيه على الارض ولا القوات
الجويه الروسيه سترغب برؤيه هذه المقاتلات
تحلق بالتالي هذه اضافه نوعيه مهمه
للامكانيات الدفاعيه الاوكرانيه
وكما قال زميلي فان المقاتلات الاف سته
عشر ستحمل ذخيره ليس وستكون مفيده ليس فقط
للقتال الجوي لكن ايضا للقتال الارضي
واستهداف القوات الارضيه بامكانها ان
تستهدف مثلا مخازنه الذخيره ومقرات القوات
بالتالي هي بالاضافه الى
المسيرات التي تستخدمها اوكرانيا وايضا
القوات التي تستخدم صواريخ
وبالتالي هي اضافه مهمه واعتقد ان هذا
الامر ان هذه الطائره ستثبت ادائها ونفسها
في في ساحات القتال السنه المقبله لو
انتقلنا الى مساله اخرى سيد في موسكو
تتعلق بما نشرته صحيفه نيويورك تايمز عن
الخسائر البشريه سواء في صفوف الروس او
الاوكرانيين هل تراها مخيفه
الفكره هنا
هو انانيق تايم طبع هذا المقال حول القوات
الروسيه كلام خاطئ تماما وغير صحيح
والفكره نرى ذلك هو التغطيه على خسائر
الحقيقيه اصابه القوات الاوكرانيه في
هجومهم مضاد لان
الخسائر
الروسيه تقل خمسه الى سته مرات عن الخسائر
الاوكرانيه اذا هل لديك ارقام تعتبرها انت
اكثر مصداقيه مما ذكرتهم
نظر روسيا فان وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قدمت
ارقام الخسائر في السنه الماضيه فقط ولذلك
الوقت كان الرقم حوالي 6000 شخص قتلوا
ولكن هل يمكن ان نعول على ارقام كهذه يعني
يبدو العدد يعني قليل جدا يعني بالنظر الى
كل ما جرى بعد اكثر من عام
نعم هذا صحيح
نسال هذا الصحيح ولكن مع الاسف ليس لدينا
اي ارقام حديثه من وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ولكن من الواضح انه بالمقارنه بين خسائر
الروسيه وخسائر الاوكرانيه بان بان هذا
موقف معروف وشائع بان الخسائر الاوكرانيه
تفوق الخصائص الروسيه بخته الى ثمان مرات
وخاصه اثناء هجومهم المضاد القضيه دائما
سيد
فيلينيوس تتعلق بمصداقيه الارقام في
الحروب كيف تراها
اعتقد اننا نعرف
وهذا هو العالم والعالم يراقب ما يحدث ان
الالاف والالاف من النساء والرجال من
القوات المسلحه الروسيه والاوكرانيه قد
لقوا مصرعهم الالاف ونضيف الى ذلك اعداد
المدنيين في اوكرانيا الذين قتلوا خلال
هذه الهجمات الصاروخيه الليليه الروسيه
الخسائر من هذه
الحرب المدنيين والعسكريين هم يصلون مئات
الالاف الامر ماساويه لاوكرانيا وماساوي
ايضا لروسيا بالتالي انت محقق حول مساله
الارقام ومدى دقتها ومصداقيتها من الصعب
معرفه الارقام بدقه لكننا نعرف فيما يتعلق
في هذا الاحتلال منذ السنه الماضيه نحن
نصل الى ارقام تصل الى مئات الالاف من
الخسائر من كل الطرفين من ضمنهم طبعا
الجانب المدني
في موسكو استندت الى مسؤولين امريكيين في
الحديث عن هذه الارقام هل تعتقد باننا
مضطرون في النهايه الى مصادر كهذه لان لا
الاوكرانيين ربما صادقين ولا الروس كذلك
في تحديد الخسائر
تماما لانه من الصعب جدا
الاعتماد على ما يسمى
باستخبارات ومصاد مخابرات الامريكيه لاغال
ما تكون مثل هذه المصادر وما يسمى المصادر
هم يضعون تعليم اضلاع تضليل اعلامي
وبالتالي
فهو مجرد
دعايه سياسيه ضد روسيا يجري التلاعب عن
طريقها بالارقام شكرا لضيفين من موسكو
اندري
ومنوس جيم تاوسنت
يتسبب القصف اليومي المتواصل على مدينه
دونيتس الشرقيه اوكرانيا بحاله من عدم
الاستقرار بالنسبه للسكان في هذه المدينه
ورغم قساوه الظروف يحاول الاهالي مواصله
حياتهم الطبيعيه بزياره المقاهي والمطامى
والمطاعم للترويح عن النفس
لم تنجلي بعد اعمده الدخان عن احياء دنيتك
ولا رائحه البارود
يخبرك المشهد هنا ان حال مدينه دنيس ليس
بافضل حال فالحرب لم تنتهي بعد ولم تنتهي
معها ماساه اناس قد يفقدون حياتهم او اعز
ما يملكون لدى سقوط اي قذيفه
وليس حال هذا الرجل العجوز بافضل من حال
مدينته
ملامحه تحكي يوميات حرب افقدته الهدوء
الذي يبحث عنه وهو في اخر مراحل حياته
وافقدته فهو اكثر احتياجا له اليوم
بعد هذا القصف فقدت رجلي هذه السياره التي
تشاهدونها ودمرت هي رجل التي اتحرك بها
فانا لا استطيع التحرك بدونها وانا
اوكراني لكنني تعبت من هذه الحرب
لم تكن صدفه ان تكون دنيتك هدفا يوميا فهي
على خط التماس جبهات القتال بين القوات
الروسيه والاوكرانيه من افيديفكا الى
امريكا
وتسجل اكثر الهجمات بمدينه دنيسكي على
احياء كييفسكي
كيروفسكي وبيروسكي ولا تستثنى كذلك
مدنوفاتا من القصف اليومي
لا هدوء في هذا المكان الذي نقف فيه الان
فهو مفتوح على جبهه لكن على بعد كيلومترات
قليله من هنا يحاول الاهالي خلق فضاء بعيد
عن اجواء الحرب
هنا عند الاصيل يتغير كل شيء يحاول هؤلاء
ولو للحظه تناسي انهم يعيشون في لجه حرب
دروس وربما يريدون استحضار ذكريات دونيت
كالجميله لعلها تبعث في قلوبهم قليلا من
الامل بغد افضل وتخفف عنهم هاجس القصف
اليومي
احاول ان انسى ما يحدث بمحيطنا لقد فقدت
وعائلتي بيتنا في القصف ناتي الى المطاعم
وهي المكان الوحيد المتاح لنا ان لم افعل
ذلك فقد اصاب بالجنون فنحن بشر ونريد ان
نعيش
لا وقت امام النسي للبقاء في الشارع
فالمدينه اعتادت ان تودع اهلها في وقت
مبكر وتنتظر دنيتك شروق يوم جديد
ويحدوها الامل بغروب صوت الحرب
[موسيقى]
في ختام قمه غير مسبوقه جمعت الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن ورئيس الوزراء الياباني
والرئيس الكوريه الجنوبي في منتجعي
اكد بيان امريكي ياباني كوري جنوبي مشترك
التزام هذه الدول الثلاث بالتشاور الفوري
وتنسيق الاستجابات للتحديات الاقليميه
والاستفزازات والتهديدات التي تؤثر على
مصالحها وامنها المشترك كما دعا البيان
الى السلام والاستقرار في تايوان ودانما
وصفه بالاعمال الخطيره والعدوانيه للصين
في بحر جنوب الصين
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن وصف القمه
الثلاثيه بالحدث التاريخي قائلا ان هذه
القمه تمثل حقبه جديده في العلاقات بين
الدول الثلاث بعيدا اكد كذلك ان هذه القمه
خلصت الى رفع مستوى التعاون الدفاعي في
مواجهه الاخطار التي قد تواجهها الدول
الثلاث
اولا تم رفع مستوى التعاون الدفاعي بين
دولنا في منطقه المحيط الهادئ بشكل غير
مسبوق مما يشمل اطلاق مناورات متعدده
المهام بشكل سنوي ومضاعفه جهود تبادل
المعلومات حول تجارب كوريا الشماليه
الصاروخيه وتمتين التعاون الدفاعي على
مستوى الاسلحه البالستيه والالتزام بتنسيق
جهود الاستجابه لاي مخاطر مهما كانت
مصادرها هذا يعني وجود خط تنسيق دائم
لمشاركه المعلومات وتنسيق الردود عندما
تدعو الحاجه الى ذلك او عند ملاحظه اي
تهديد لاي من دولنا اليوم اكدنا ايضا على
التزامنا المشترك بالحفاظ على السلام
والاستقرار في مضيق تايوان وتمثيل التكامل
الاقتصادي
وقبل القمه حرس مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي جاك سلفن عفوا على القول ان هذا
التعاون الثلاثي المعزز ليس بمثابه حلف
اطلسي في المحيط الهادئ اما في بيجين فقد
دعا المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الصينيه على
عدم تحويل منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ الى
ساحه للمنافسه الجو السياسيه وقال ان
محاوله حشد الدوائر وخلق التكتلات
العسكريه ستثير بالتاكيد يقظه ومعارضه دول
المنطقه وفق تعبيرهم
ثلاثه ضد ثلاثه هل هذا ما سينتهي اليه
الامر في قمه كام ديفيد المنتجع المعروف
تاريخيا بقمم غيرت سياسات دول احيانا الى
النقيض هو الان مهدو ولاده تحالف ثلاثي
امريكي ياباني كوري جنوبي في سبيل مواجهه
الصين تتنسى الصول وتوكيو خصومه تاريخيه
حاضره في ذاكره الشعبين القمه الاولى
الرسميه وليست على هامش قمه بين الثلاثي
هي رساله للتنين المستيقظ بتوقيع الرئيس
جو بايدن والرئيس الوزراء الياباني
والرئيس الكوريه الجنوبي يونسوكيو محاولات
المسؤولين الامريكيين في انتقاء المفردات
للحديث عن اجنده اللقاء واهدافه من قبيل
ان المحادثات ليست لانشاء تحالف دفاعي
وغير موجهه ضد الدوله معينه لم يقنع
كثيرين قبل ساعات من الموعد تحدث مستشار
الامن القومي الامريكي عن رؤيه ايجابيه
وعن التزام ثلاثي للتشاور
بصراحه القمه ليست لاقامه حلف على غرار
النيتو للمحيط الهادئ كما قلنا واكدنا مع
اليابان وكوريا اود ان اؤكد فقط ان قمه
ليس ضد اي شخص بل تهدف الى تحقيق رؤيه
المحيطين الهندي والهادئ للامن والازدهار
في المنطقه
بلغه اخرى على الطاوله نقاش بشان تفاصيل
اتفاقيه لتبادل المعلومات الاستخباراتيه
المتعلقه بكوريا الشماليه وايضا التركيز
على مساله تعزيز الردع الذي قدمته وعشره
لاحتواء الصين بينما كان القاده في طريقهم
الى كان ديفيد دعا المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الصينيه الى عدم تحويل منطقه اسيا والمحيط
الهادئ الى ساحه منافسه جيوسيه
في مواجهه الوضع الامنيه الدوليه المضطرب
يجب على جميع الاطراف التمسك بمفهوم
المجتمع الامني والالتزام بالتعدديه
الحقيقيه والاستجابه المشتركه للتحديات
الامنيه المختلفه لا ينبغي لاي دوله ان
تسعى الى تحقيق امنها على حساب المصالح
الامنيه للدول الاخرى والسلام والاستقرار
الاقليميين
التقارب الصيني الروسي الكوري الشمالي بعد
قنديفيد موعود باحداث ستزيد من غضبي وتوجس
الثلاثي الاخر المناورات العسكريه
المشتركه الثنائيه ليست سوى نقطه في بحر
التهديدات المتبادله والمستمره اختتمت
البحريه الصينيه والروسيه تدريبات مضاده
للغواصات ومحاكاه هجوم جوي مفترض فرضت
زياره وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجي شوي
لكوريا الشماليه في يوليو الماضي قراءه
واستنتاجات بشكل التحالفات والتحالفات
المضاده في المنطقه الجديده منها والقديمه
خريطه طريق غربيه اسيويه لقطع الطريق على
الصين وحلفائها ترى النور في مناخ
جيوسياسي كله عواصف وهوجاء
[موسيقى]
صراع النفوذ والعلاقات مستمر بين الصين
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه في المحيطين
الهندي والهادر علاقات متشابكه احكموها
المصالح والاقتصاديه والخلافات الحدود
واستقطاب المستمر لا يتوقف منذ عقود هذه
هي الدول التي ترتبط مع الولايات المتحده
بتحالفات استراتيجيه ومصالحه او ببين نحو
واشنطن ضد الصين ابرزها كما نرى اليابان
واستراليا وكوريا الجنوبيه الفلبين وكذلك
تايوان وتايوان احد مواطن الخلافه
الاساسيه كما نعلم بين واشنطن وبيجين
بينما رايت ايضا الهند التي يحرك صراع
النفوذ بينها وبين الصين اصطفافاتها هذه
الدول في المقابل التي نراها باللون
الاحمر كما نرى على الشاشه تعد اكثر قربا
للصين وذلك في سياق العلاقات بتلك المنطقه
نعلم منها كوريا الشماليه بطبيعه الحال
بشكل اساسي بينما نرى دولا اخرى مخططه
باللون الاحمر تميل نحو السجن لكن ذلك لا
يلغي الاشاره الى نمو في علاقات الصين
باتجاه ما يعرف بدول طريق الحرير الجديد
في تلك المنطقه نرى هذه الدول باللون
الرمادي باللون الرمادي والتي تعتبر
حياديه في مشهد التوتر الامريكي الصيني في
ظل هذه الخارطه كانت الولايات المتحده
محورا في اكثر من تحالف ابرز تلك
التحالفات التحالف اكوس بين الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا واستراليا ويشمل
التعاون في تطوير الاسلحه وقدرات الحرب
الالكترونيه في محاوله لمواجهه هيمنه
الصين في المحيط الهادي وقد دشن هذا
التحالف في سبتمبر ايلول 2021
ويشتمل تعاون اكوس مجالات الحرب
الالكترونيه والذكاء الاصطناعي وبموجيبه
منحت واشنطن ولندن التكنولوجيا لاستراليا
لبناء غواصات تعمل بالطاقه النوويه هناك
ايضا الاتفاق الرباعي وهو تحالف لمواجهه
توسع النفوذ الصيني في اسيا والمحيط
الهادئ ويضم الولايات المتحده والهند
واستراليا واليابان ويشمل هذا التحالف
تعاونا لتبادل المعلومات والتدريبات
العسكريه وغيرها للولايات المتحده كذلك
تحالفات ثنائيه مع دول المنطقه ففي
اليابان تمتلك واشنطن قواعد جويه في اكثر
من مكان كما يقع مقر الاسطول السابع
الرئيسي في الياباني تمتلك واشنطن كذلك
قواعد جويه ومعسكرات لجيش المشاه البحريه
في كوريا الجنوبيه
معنا الان من لندن
الباحث في دراسات الامن بمنطقه الشرق اسيا
في جامعه كينس كوليج في لندن اهلا وسهلا
بك سيد مورغن هذه القمه الثلاثيه وهذا
التعاون هل نعول عليه بالنسبه للمستقبل
كتحالف متين
شكرا على الاستضافه ويسرني ان اكون معكم
اعتقد ان قمه التي حصلت اليوم كانت
اجتماعا مهما للغايه اعتقد انها كانت قمه
مهمه ووجودها فيد له رمزيه كبيره واعتقد
انه بناء على شيء قمتم بذكره في التقرير
انه هو رغبه من قبل الولايات المتحده ان
تحقق تعاونا افضل بين جمهوريه كوريا
الجنوبيه واليابان وهو شيء كان يتهدف
الولايات المتحده لتحقيقه وفي اوقات ربما
افضل من الان اعتقد ان التحالفات الثنائيه
التحالفات
والاتفاقيات التي لدى الولايات المتحده مع
اليابان ومع المملكه المتحده هي قويه
واعتقد انها الان تحاول ان تبني هذه
الشراكه الثلاثيه اجتماع اليوم كان مهما
لكنه في حقيقه الامر كان يبني على خطوات
كانت بدات منذ عام 2020 في جمهوريه كوريا
الجنوبيه رغم ان هذه القمه السيد مورجن
حاولت ان ان تتجنب الاشاره الى الصين والى
كوريا الشماليه ولكن واضح ان هذا التكتل
هو ضد هذين البلدين هل هذا سيزيد التوتر
في المنطقه
اعتقد انه اذا ما نظرنا الى البيانات التي
خرجت من القمه وان روح
وهذه البيانات المشتركه والمبادئ التي كشف
عنها البيان باستطاعتنا ان نرى ما الذي
تهدف اليه القمه ما هو الذي كان كان
يتحدثون عنه ويتحدث عن التحديات والفرص
روسيا ايضا تم ذكرها ربما بخجل وكوريا
الشماليه ايضا تم ذكرها ايضا تم الاشاره
الى الصين فيما يتعلق
بالنشاطات والمزاعم البحريه غير القانونيه
وهنالك تذكير ذكر ضمني واشاره الى
المنافسه الجياسيه ايضا لا اعتقد ان
الطريق التي تم اداره فيها هذه القمه
والبيانات التي خرج منها ستزيد من
التوتر لكنني متاكد انه سيكون هنالك
بيانات سل
ردا عليها من قبل كوريا الشماليه ولربما
بيانات افعال حذره من الصين تحذروا عن
مساله تزايد التحالفات التي قد تهدف الى
احتواء الصين من الصين ايضا وصلت ردود
الفعل هذه وزير الخارجيه الصيني في فيديو
توجه الى
اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه بالقول لن تصبح
اوروبيين او امريكيين حتى ولو اصبح شعركم
اشقر وعيونكم زرقاء وبالتالي عليكم ان
تعودوا الى المنطقه
وتحالفات المنطقه هل يمكن ان تستمع هذه
الدول لمثل هذه النداءات الصينيه
بالتاكيد هنالك بعد اقليمي وجمهوريه كوريا
واليابان مهمان في المنطقه كلاهما
مهماني على الاقتصادات عالميه مهمه وايضا
بوجود سياسات خارجيه خاصه بهما وهنالك
ايضا
درجه عاليه من المصالح المشتركه بين القيم
وفي المجالات الاقتصاديه وفيما يتعلق ايضا
في الانظمه الديمقراطيه بين جمهوريه كوريا
واليابان وبين الدول الغربيه لكنني اعتقد
انه ربما
تعليق ورد تقليدي من الصين اعتقد انه في
كل الاوقات ترغب الصين باضعاف العلاقات
بين الولايات المتحده واليابان وبين
الكوريا واليابان وايضا ان هذا قد انها اي
تحالفا قد يمثل ضغطا على الصين واما هذا
رد الفعل الصيني ليس مفاجئا تحدث عن طابع
مؤسساتي وعن قمه سنويه هل سيترسخ ذلك بشكل
جدي
هل بامكانك ان تعيد السؤال لو سمحت
تحدث عن قمه سنويه ستعقد بين هذه الدول
الثلاث وان سيصبح لها طابع مؤسساتي هل
يمكن فعلا التعويل على توجه من هذا القبيل
نعم نعم اعتقد ان من الواضح ان هنالك عدم
وضوح نحو المستقبل عندما يكون هنالك تغيير
في الادارات لاي في اي من هذه الدول وخاصه
عندما يكون هنالك ربما انتخابات رئاسيه في
الولايات المتحده في عام 2024
بالتاكيد فان احتماليه نتائج مختلفه وارده
بشكل كبير اعتقد انه
هنالك اواصر مؤسساتيه قويه بين كوريا
واليابان وبين الولايات المتحده بشكل
ثلاثي هنالك اجتماعات ثلاثيه
الاعلان قال بشكل واضح انه سيؤسس نحو
المزيد وتعزيز هذه الاواصر المؤسساتيه على
المستوى التقني فيما يتعلق بتبادل
المعلومات الاستخباراتيه والمعلومات وايضا
في مساله المسؤولين الكبار في الادارات
الثلاث اعتقد ان هذه الاواصر وهذه الاواصل
المؤ سساتيه
تهدف الى تامين مستقبل العلاقات
وانا اعمل ان هذا هو الوضع الذي سنشده
مستقبلا لكنني في حقيقه الامر لا استطيع
التنبؤ اذا ما كان وهنالك تغيير في
الادارات لكن قد امل انه لن يؤثر على
العلاقات المستقبليه شكرا جزيلا لك الاست
[موسيقى]
خطير يصبح الانسان او يصبح خطيرا فعلا
عندما يتجرد من انسانيته وفي العالم قصص
كثيره في هذا السياق هذه هي لوسي ليتبي
ممرضه بريطانيه اذينت اليوم بجريمه بشعه
يندرها حيث قتلت سبعه اطفال سبعه اطفال
حديثي الولاده عن طريق حقنهم بالهوى حاولت
قتل سته اخرين قبل ان يتم القبض عليها
اكتشفت هذه الجريمه الشنيعه لكن جرائم
كثيره في العالم تقيد للاسف ضد مجهول
مجهول اختار ان يزرع في البيوت ما اسيا
يصعب تجاوزها قيمنا الانسانيه مهمه
والتنازل عنها مؤذن للكثيرين نهايه حصاد
الليله تصبحون على خير
[موسيقى]